Hey youtubers it’s charlie and this week
on walking dead we found out what happened
to the rest of the prison including the remaining
people from the governor’s group.
One really big character came back and we
got a huge teaser for their next major destination.
Quick shoutout for my weekly giveaway if you’re
finding me for the first time.
I’ll be selecting one subscriber at random
from the comments to give a twenty dollar
amazon gift card to.
I’ll announce the winner during my walking
dead Q&A video tomorrow night.
All you have to do is be a subscriber and
leave a comment to win.
But if you want me to include a specific question
in that Q&A, just let me know.
Careful for spoilers from episode 10 if you
haven’t seen it yet, but let’s start with
our top 5 moments and then I’ll do my review.
Number 5 - Beth and Daryl’s extended camping
trip.
Their whole extended scene was so much fun.
A lot of comic book readers will remember
that for a brief moment they hooked up, but
since the show messes with a lot of minor
details like that I’m not expecting anything
super sexual to go down between them.
Even Daryl’s relationship with Carol got
muted a lot.
Pookie.
Number 4 - Glenn realizes he’s all alone
again.
Glenn just loses it and it wasn’t fun to
watch, but it was really intense.
I didn’t freak out too much, just because
Glenn always does really well on his own.
I keep remembering that scene from season
1 with him in the charger.
To be fair though, he gets himself into as
many problems as he gets himself out of.
Which is where his better half comes in.
Number 3 - Maggie loses her shit trying to
find glenn.
There are so many tumblr gifs of maggie going
crazy and after this episode there will be
several new ones.
I can only imagine what their children will
end up being like when they grow up someday.
I feel like that’s a spoiler for my prediction
that they’ll both survive this season.
If one of them does die though, I think maggie
will be the one.
Lauren Cohan does such an amazing job of selling
anguish and desperation.
They kept trying to fake us out that Glenn
was on the bus, but we saw him in the teaser
last week.
So the moment had already been spoiled.
Number 2 - Abraham’s group to the rescue.
Took them long enough.
We knew they were coming at the end of last
year, but we didn’t know which episode they’d
debut in or which group would run into them.
I think it’s great that it was Tara.
Obviously Glenn is out cold so he’ll meet
them later.
But this gives Tara the opportunity to start
fresh.
She was so hung up on the idea of redemption
and Glenn did an amazing job of explaining
the difference between wants and needs given
the need to find the rest of the survivors.
Number 1 - Carol Shows Up with Baby Judith,
Lizzie and Meeka.
There were a lot of WTF moments, but Carol
coming back this early and pulling off such
a big save was my favorite.
I think of Carol’s entrance as like a reverse
Batman.
Like instead of dissapearing when you turn
around, she magically appears.
I love that quick pause she has when she sees
that tyreese has seen her.
She doesn’t know whether or not he knows
about Karen.
I’m expecting him to find out soon, but
it seems like for now all will be well between
them.
Honorable Mention goes to Lizzie and Mika,
normally I don’t like little kids on intense
drama shows like Walking Dead, but Lizzie
is so hardcore now that watching her try to
fill Carol’s shoes was really fun.
I feel like a lot of her maturation happened
off screen.
We really only saw her getting yelled at by
Carol and then during the prison plague she
just kind of tuned everything out and went
dead inside.
Cut to the prison attack where she’s gunning
people down without a second though.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moment was.
And do you think that Abraham’s group will
go for the sanctuary too?
Because it seems like everyone else is headed
there.
I’m so excited to see what new dynamic Abraham,
rosita and eugene add to the show this season
and how the rest of the survivors interact
with them.
Right now it’s really just tara and glenn
until they meet up at the sanctuary.
Overall I really liked the episode.
It was another huge shift from the carl-driven
episode last week.
I gave that episode an A and I feel like I
have to give this episode at least an A minus.
The only issue in using the entire ensemble
is that you don’t get as many chances to
develop characters.
Glenn is the exception this time though.
He’s a character that you are really used
to thinking of as a loner, so why wouldn’t
he show up alone after the prison fight.
I love that he helped Tara out.
I can’t wait to see how she tries to redeem
herself for the rest of the season.
She’s like the new Lizzie of the show now.
Small and helpless but on the path to being
a badass.
I also thought the way the constructed the
story was a lot of fun.
All of the different groups started out from
the same moment in time and things just branched
from there.
That’s why we kept seeing the same locations
in different times.
Because the character experienced them in
different times.
I want that sign for my room though.
Warning Hitchhikers may be escaping inmates.
Like i said, I’ll announce the winner of
this week’s giveaway in the Q&A video tomorrow.
I’ll be picking one random subscriber from
the comments.
Right now click here for last week’s episode
and click here for the game of thrones trailer
that just posted tonight.
So much new footage, there be dragons here.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!